[Music]
remember
what is Cristiano Ronaldo you know where
in my pocket
[Music]
I can't even begin to describe what I'm
feeling to be the first African team to
make the semi-finals the first Arab team
to make the semi-finals and I said this
before I said it when we started and I'm
gonna say it again we're going all the
way to the top for the first time you
see all the Arabs are united it's a lot
it's a lot of Hope for every single Arab
country yes we believe in our team we
believe that we have a strong team and
it was just today we demonstrate that
Morocco is a great team we will carry
the cup we will carry the cup
this way
[Music]
[Applause]